[Aplausos]
una medida que discrimina a los más
pobres esto es lo que piensan los
manifestantes que protestaron en las
calles de madrid en contra de la nueva
restricción durante la bandera desde el
pasado viernes la presidenta de la
comunidad de madrid isabel díaz ayuso
anunció que a partir de este lunes los
casi 800 60.000 habitantes de 37 zonas
no podrán salir de sus barrios
allí los parques estarán cerrados y los
restaurantes y tiendas solo podrán abrir
con la mitad del aforo y hasta las 10 de
la noche hora local la única excepción
para ir a otros distritos es para
quienes deban trabajar estudiar o acudir
a una cita médica 37 áreas en toda la
comunidad de madrid' donde la incidencia
es muy superior de hecho estamos
hablando de mil contagios por cada
100.000 habitantes más cifra gravísima
aunque las autoridades explican que las
nuevas restricciones para proteger a las
comunidades de la rápida propagación del
virus muchos consideran que es una
medida discriminatoria porque se aplica
en zonas donde principalmente viven
migrantes y personas de bajos recursos
además no le ven sentido que si puedan
ir a trabajar a los barrios ricos de
madrid porque lo que no es lógico es que
pueda ser a trabajar al barrio dejar
pero no puedes irte a hacer compras por
ejemplo porque al final si estás
contagiado
puedes cantar claro te puedes contar
crear de allí del trabajo dónde está
es por eso también que planté
y por gente es criminal
este domingo las protestas llegaron
hasta la asamblea el parlamento de la
comunidad de madrid'
también hubo manifestaciones en 12 de
las 37 zonas que estarán limitadas todo
con la consigna de más inversión en
salud y la renuncia de la presidenta de
la comunidad autónoma